did you know that only around 30% of us
households regularly keep a budget
despite its bad rap as a joy killer
budgeting is a skill like driving
without it you're basically wandering
around aimlessly hoping to end up where
you want to be so here are three tips on
how to exercise your budgeting muscles
budget with money you have there's no
point in trying to tell the future start
allocating the money you've already
earned or saved then as new money comes
in add that to the plan every sing Sing
dollar should be assigned to a specific
spending or savings purpose if you want
to buy something impulsively you will
have to make a conscious decision is
that Taylor Swift ticket really worth
depleting your emergency fund don't just
set it and forget it if you want to keep
moving towards your goals you can't just
fall asleep at the wheel there are lots
of apps that will help keep you honest
about what your plans were versus what
actually happened that way you can spend
and save with confidence